welcome back to CBS this morning I'm
Gayle King with Anthony Mason and Tony
to copal we begin with this Puerto Rico
the governor under fire they're facing
new calls to resign over leaked
conversation that reveal his role in a
profane sexist and homophobic group chat
the island as you know has struggled to
recover from Hurricane Maria back in
2017 and Governor Ricardo resales
administration has been plagued by
scandals involving funding to top
officials stepped down over the weekend
after the leaked conversation it show
drew say oh and his allies discussing
confidential government information and
disparaging officials politicians and
journalists CTM lead national
correspondent David beg no is among the
people targeted in that chat what he's
in San Juan David I'm very curious about
this conversation and stretchy to hear
you were someone who was targeted what
are they saying well they didn't like
one of the reports we did about crime on
the island Gail so they talked about
attacking us on social media
specifically me to discredit our
reporting because they said we were
going to kill tourism on the island the
governor was the administrator of this
secret chat room that had 11 other
people they talked about setting up a
troll network to go after people who
they didn't like the chats are profane
very vulgar but beyond that what's
really important is there's information
that could become the subject of a
federal investigation to determine
whether or not a crime was committed the
governor says he will not resign but
ever since the chats were leaked the
protests have not stopped
overnight fireworks right in front of
the governor's mansion were a show of
protest demonstrators are demanding that
the 40-year old governor resign
Sunday morning as his political support
was collapsing around him the governor
went to church saying he had sought
forgiveness the leaked chat room
conversations between the governor and
11 others are laced with profane
homophobic and sexist comments and in
one case talk of violence against the
mayor of San Juan Carmen Jolene Cruz the
governor's chief financial officer
Christian sobrino wrote I'm dying to
shoot her up the governor responded
you'd be doing me a big favor
I think they lit a lot of illegal things
during these conversations
Carla Mina leads Puerto Rico's center
for investigative journalism which
published 889 pages of the conversations
they were part of a conspiracy to
persecute people because of political
beliefs
I think definitely they use public funds
to do a political word that is just last
week the FBI arrested two of the
governor's former top officials on fraud
charges involving more than 15 million
dollars of federal funding the
governor's administration has been under
scrutiny for its spending of government
funds after Hurricane Maria devastated
the island in 2017 basically our
Caribbean scholar URI Mar Bonilla writes
about post hurricane Maria recovery the
government is distracted thinking about
its image worrying about how they're
being represented in the press instead
of attending to the matters of the
recovery that is reassuring on democracy
Arnaldo claudia was one of the people
targeted in the group chat he was
appointed by the Justice Department five
years ago to bring reform to Puerto
Rico's police department if this is not
right at all and he needs to be
condemned they cannot have people like
this trying to coerce people or trying
to use okay their level in government to
harm people it's wrong
that man you just saw has gone to the
FBI and asked them to open an
investigation the Governor of Puerto
Rico says what he said in the chat room
was simply venting because he was
overworked and he was letting some steam
off the governor's party 48 hours ago
looked like they were going to abandon
him potentially try to impeach him but
late last night Tony they changed their
- now they're saying we're gonna give
him a chance to catch his breath and
reflect on what he does next we asked
the governor for an interview they
haven't gotten back to us and by the way
there's a report on the island just this
morning that says more chat messages
will be leaked very soon all right David
thank you very much yeah I would think
David he's not looking forward to
talking to you I'm just gonna go by his
place what's your next plan to get him
well we can't even get to the governor's
mansion because it's blocked off you
have these protesters here who set up
throughout the night and didn't leave
there are more protests planned for
later today but I'm gonna put in another
request in about an hour see if we can
talk to it all right keep monitoring the
chat rooms yes yes